sur le détroit de Gibraltar il y a un
jeune noir qui boit dans ce bar où les
espoirs se bousculent une simple canette
de Fanta il cherche comme un chien sans
collier le foin et qui n'a en fait
jamais eu et se dit que peut-être
bientôt
il ne cherchera plus
et ça arrive autour de lui et ça pleure
au fond de lui toutes ces millions de
d'enfants de femmes et d'hommes qu'on
appelle les migrants que moi j'appelle
les exilés ce voyage qu'ils font ils le
font tout simplement pour trouver un
endroit et pourront véritablement
s'épanouir en tant qu'être être heureux
comme n'importe quel être humain le
destin de ses exilés en fait c'est le
destin de notre humanité dans son
entièreté on a l'impression qu'on suit
l'histoire de suivre les exilés
habituels et puis on se rend compte que
quelque part on est tous exilé en fait
[Musique]